okay hello everybody let me get started
here I want to introduce myself so my
name is Stephanie Wyrick I'm a professor
at Penn and for the past so 13 years
I've been doing a lot of work extending
the type system of the Glasgow Haskell
compiler of GHC so today I want to talk
to you about what we can do with those
type system extensions and and
specifically dependent types in Haskell
now how many here have used Haskell
before yeah great
great right and so if you've used
Haskell for maybe you know like me you
appreciate that
it's mathematical character that it
comes straight from the lambda calculus
right but ever since I was a little girl
and I found out about Penna types I kind
of wanted more from this language but
you know there's just not a PI in
Haskell right nobody can use a PI type
here so so what do I do about it
all right well I had a point know I add
a whole bunch of language extensions
mostly to increase the expressiveness of
the compile the type system and I'm
gathering together a whole bunch
together that I typically use some of
them the ones in red are ones that I've
worked on the ones a blue or others and
they all kind of work together to give
something that I call I like to call it
dependent Haskell because when I program
with these languages extensions I feel
like I'm programming in a dependently
typed language alright and so I want to
explain that how that works to you and
I'm going to do that by showing you an
extended example of what I consider to
be a dependent typed program written in
Haskell right so you might be wondering
why do all this why why do you want to
have dependent types in the first place
all right and and there's lots of
reasons the reason for today the
motivating my example that I'm going to
show you is because we want the type
checker that's Haskell's type checker to
know about our
application to know about our domain
that we're working with we don't want
the type checker to just give us help us
rule out general purpose bugs we also
want the type checker to rule out domain
specific box all right so let's look at
a domain so here's just a simple little
domain I've worked out it's just a
simple example just to show you I'm not
saying you should go use this library
but I want to walk through how this
library can take advantage of dependent
types so it's based on regular
expression CAPTCHA groups so you might
have a string like this and you might
define a regular expression to recognize
this string as a as a it's a file name
my file path and you might use some
capture groups to pull out parts of it
right so we might look for the base name
part of the file path and and want to
find out you parse it into that string
we might find an extension that may or
may not be there we might want to look
for some directories and find out what
all of the directories are in the past
so I've written a little library that
will do this for a regular expression
it's loosely based on how capture groups
work and other other languages though
most most of the time other languages
won't give you multiple answers but I
wanted to show that off and the
important part where two types come in
the type system we're going to get our
result from our right from our matching
it's gonna be a dictionary it's gonna
tell you you know the base name is this
the extension is this the type system
should help govern that dictionary
access so let me show you how it works I
knew I would do that let me show you how
it works in practice so let's go over to
Haskell so here is a little module that
is using my library right and right here
this is my regular expression that has
the capture groups that I'm going to be
using for parsing this string right here
so let me walk through the regular
expression for you regular expressions
are more complicated than dependent
types
okay so we have so between that pipe and
the other pipe down there is the regular
expression itself maybe we start with a
beginning slash then from this paren to
here this is for the directories and I'm
adopted pythons way of naming capture
groups so question mark P der this is
the name of the capture group inside of
it is a regular expression that is
supposed to be what a directory name
looks like we could have multiple
directory names so we have a star
outside of that capture group here's the
base name so from this / end to here
we're again correct capturing it with a
group named base here's the regular
expression for the base name there's
only one base name here is the extension
we may or may not have an extension so
we have a question mark but it's named
next and it's anywhere from the last dot
okay so that's the regular expression
here's a string and let me go down a
little bit
here's the line that is running my
function that matches that regular
expression against that string and I
know it's gonna succeed so I'm gonna
course it's gonna give me a maybe you
know it could fail but I know it's gonna
succeed so it's gonna give me a
dictionary and then here I want to
access the components from that
dictionary
right I want to pull out what is the
base name what is that list of
directories and what is that extension
alright so let me just show you that
this works so I haven't loaded
I already loaded it into GAC I but I can
say okay there's the base name
there's the directories there is the
expansion now those of you coming from
Python or JavaScript you're not
impressed
right you do this all the time right so
let me show you something you can't do
let's try to access a field that's not
in that dictionary so I didn't name
anything in the regular expression named
F I'm just gonna call let's uncomment
that and I'll reload all right and now I
got a type error and here's my type
error
right my type error is telling me that I
just can't do that that dictionary the
type of that dictionary is tailored from
the regular expression it knows exactly
what kind of capture groups are
available right base directs or the only
capture groups since I asked for F it's
gonna give it's gonna refuse to compile
my code that would be a bug in my
program and so it has found a bug for me
right and my library has allowed me to
even customize juicy has a mechanism for
customizing the type error messages so I
can even make sure with my domain
specific type system I have a domain
specific error message going on right
and even back up here notice what's
going on with x + y + Z so oh I have to
make it compile again but right it's
able to figure out the X x y&z all have
different types I don't know if you can
see down here it's showing the types of
what these variables are that the type
checker has inferred right so Z the
extension it's optional so maybe it's
going to be a string the list of
directories is a list of strings right
there are no type annotations in this
program the library has figured out how
to determine this information right so
this is the you know that's what I want
to do that's what I want dependent types
to do for me so let me kind of unpack
this a little bit and show you how that
works
all right and I'm gonna impact this by
asking this question you know when we
say two kind of types what do we mean
right because Haskell's not a
dependently typed language clearly yep
and so I've kind of taken the idea of
dependently type dependent type systems
what did dependent type systems provide
and isolated four different things that
are related to each other but there are
four different capabilities that your
type system can provide and that this
example is taking advantage of that I'm
using to implement this library so then
I'm going to walk through each of these
four capabilities and kind of explain
why it's important to this example and
what is going on in GHC to support it
all right so the first thing is I want
to program the type checker right all
right you saw that somehow I had to tell
the type checker about what capture
groups are in regular expressions right
and so I was using the type system to
implement this domain-specific
compile-time analysis all right so
that's what I call type computation
being able to program in your types and
it really is programming so here I have
my regular expression and I didn't show
you this but I could we could ask G G
HCI what's its type and this is actually
what it would show you is the type of
this value is a very informative type to
be able to do that to check that
dictionary it has to know quite a bit
right so it knows that it's a regular
expression but this regular expression
type is more is this huge component here
that I'm calling an occurrence map all
right this is just a list of mappings
from the CAPTCHA group name and
something that's called an occurrence it
tells me how often that group is going
to could get captured by that regular
expression you know maybe by the like
the base name it only gets captured once
maybe we might
many times like the directories and
maybe we may or may not capture it right
all right so this information is what's
going is what the rest of the system is
going to use to govern that dictionary
access right and the Haskell has type
level lists and strings that are called
type level symbols this is a promoted
data type this is a normal Haskell data
type that I'm using in the types all
right just like an enumeration right now
how do we get from that term to this
type the first step is a little bit of
template Haskell so those of you you
might have recognized that these
brackets invoke template Haskell which
is some compile time meta programming it
it all it does is it invokes a parser
for regular expressions that I've
written so at compile time it runs the
parser and it translates that regular
expression string to this bit of code
right which is another way of
representing the abstract syntax of a
regular expression using some
Constructors for this regular expression
type that maile library creates so we
have you know this is creates a regular
expression that only accepts a single
character
this creates takes two regular
expressions and creates a sequence of it
this one iterates the regular expression
right it's just parsing into the
abstract syntax in the first step and
then the compile time type reasoning
that compile time programming all
happens in what the types of those
constructors are that's where the real
magic is because what happens is
template Haskell parses for two's is
this and then the type checker runs
right and the all of these operators
have very informative types that can
compute this type for this particular
expression so let's look at the types of
those operators right
so some of them are pretty
straightforward right you know the
regular expression that doesn't that
only matches the empty string doesn't
capture any capture groups alright so
I'm just using an empty list as it's a
currents map it's saying there's no
there's not going to be any capture
groups from here
all right things get a little more
interesting when we build up regular
expressions so if we make an alternative
regular expression right you'll see that
you know we're gonna have some
occurrence map here it's going to
capture some groups that's going to
capture some groups what groups this is
the entire regular expression capture
well that's defined by this type level
function that I have written
all right this type level function takes
these two data structures that the type
checker is manipulating runs the
function and computes what the
alternation is going to capture so again
I'm gonna go back to geo CI and kind of
show you how this works through example
instead of walking through what those
functions do so down here so mark is the
one that create that says this is a this
is a regular expression that should mark
a sub string to create a capture group
right so if you look at our a and our B
right our a down here captures one a
captures a wants our B captures B wants
it doesn't really matter what very good
expression it's using the match it but
it knows that it's matching a B what if
I do an RB and then an RA put them in
sequence together right then the
function that I wrote for our seeked for
its type merges those two occurrence
maps together it also sorts them so I
have a uniform representation of those
currents Maps so it's sorting and again
it's a lot like a merge sort all right
what about what if I alternate so think
about if I here on the right side have
RB with an R a after it
what if I said either that one or just
an RA how many times is that going to
capture RA I'm an a how many times is
that going to capture a B all right well
Haskell figures that out right it's
always going to capture an A but it may
or may not capture a B right if you can
see here is once B is optional okay what
about a star right so here if I have our
star
I want to iterate I want to do zero more
occurrences right in this case we don't
know how many times we could get an A or
B we started with doing a or B exactly
once but we could do it many times and
many includes zero okay so we have these
functions and they run with the type
checker to calculate these occurrence
Maps okay okay now what what do we do
once we have those occurrence Maps
all right well that's where the next
idea comes in we're using those
occurrence Maps these description of
what's going on with the capture groups
we're using that to constrain values and
this is what I mean when I say index
types the re this regular expression
type it's an index type it's indexed by
this occurrence map and that a cross map
is going to UM it's gonna make a huge
difference for the type checker right so
when we have a regular expression that's
indexed by a capture group if it
successfully matches it's going to
produce a dictionary and the dictionary
type is going to be indexed by exactly
the same occurrence map right so when I
match Ari then I'm going to produce a
dictionary that has exactly the same map
right and then what does that tell me
about my dictionary
all right I'm indexing that dictionary
type by this occurrence map that tells
me a lot about that dictionary right
because the
hey I've set up the dictionary type it's
gonna force the structure of the
dictionary to look something like this
now maybe it's going to be different
strings but it's always going to be an
entry with a string for bass an entry
with a list of strings for the
directories an entry with an optional
string and maybe string for the
extension and that's it and nothing else
from the type I know at compile time
what the values of this type must look
like all right not any arbitrary
sequences of that of entries it's
something that matches this pattern
right and that's good all right
on one hand note what's missing from
from this value there's no keys right
baster a next they're not stored with
the values Y that's kind of redundant we
already know what they are we just look
at the type right and the type is gonna
tell us if we need to look up things in
this dictionary it says okay go do the
first thing you know exactly where to go
at compile time
so at compile time my library tells
Haskell how exactly how to access the
base component so that get filled at
base that's resolved at compile time
and that's important that it's resolved
at compile time because when I start
asking things that aren't there that's
how I can have a compile time error
message right if I ask for a field
that's not present in that dictionary
okay now how is it that we go from this
type to knowing exactly that it has this
structure and here I'm using an
extension to GHC that's called gadgets
it's a generalization of the algebraic
data types in in Haskell and you may
have seen in other languages they look a
lot like normal data types but there are
indexed this one they're indexed by
other's types and that index is allowed
to change in the Constructors so
dictionaries are indexed by
Curren Maps if we have a dictionary
indexed with the empty map it must be
the empty dictionary it can't be any
other dictionary if it's indexed by a
non empty occurrence map right so if
it's indexed by an occurrence map that
looks like this maps this symbol to that
occurrence alright then we have to have
an entry for that symbol and that
occurrence and then whatever the rest of
the dictionary is we have to have more
of that alright so be defining the type
in this way is how we establish that
constraint okay now let me show you a
little bit about how the entries work so
entry here's a here's something that has
an entry type this might be an entry for
an extension right the e is the
constructor for the entry type here's
the value that that constructor is gonna
carry doesn't have this is not the only
type that this expression has notice how
the extension it's a here in the type
it's nowhere in the value we could give
lots of different types but that I
happen to have given this type to this
value right and when I create an entry
it's another indexed type it's a type
that's indexed by these two things right
the name of the capture group and the
incurrence but in this case the really
important thing with is entry is what
type of data it holds and that type of
data is determine calculated by this
type level function that I'm calling awk
type alright this octet function it
takes one of these occurrences and it's
going to map that incurrence to the type
of data that should be stored in that
entry so the second index here is
constraining the type of data so when I
have opt then they awk type for OPS's I
need to have an optional string value
there and that's the only kind of string
value that's the only kind of value that
can be stored if the index is odd okay
so we're using these index types to make
very strong constraints on what our data
looks like
okay now the next thing what we're doing
now this is it's something that I'm
calling double duty data right what does
that mean
all right I'm actually using data in my
program in two different ways
I'm using it in the type indices but
sometimes I need to use it at run time
so let me show you where we end up doing
that in this library right so here I
have this dictionary the type tells me
what it looks like and I let's print it
out and so we can print it out and have
school prints it out okay why is this
weird well when you print something out
there's no types at run time all right
Haskell erases all types before it runs
your program where are those base come
from when we're printing it out how does
it know how to what type of value to
print all right that's where we have to
we actually do have to somehow preserve
the types to run time a little bit just
to be able to do things like this all
right and so if we were in a dependently
typed language like idris or Agda this
is where pi would come into play all
right I would write a function you know
for showing a dictionary it would have a
it would need to call a function called
show the entry for me tell me how to
take one of these entries and turn it
into a string and it would have a PI
type right and the reason it has a PI
type is because we need to quantify over
the key and the occurrence right for a
particular entry mapping a key to an
appearance but then we also need to use
the key in the occurrence when we're
printing it out we need to call it a
helper function that's going to show
what that key is and when we show the
data we need to know what the occurrence
is to know exactly how to show that data
right so for example here show data
itself has to have a PI type because
it's going to show the kind of data for
that entry and the type of it is awk
typo we need to interpret that to a type
right and so we
need to match here and say okay if the
occurrence is wants then we need a show
function that's going to convert our
string to a string if it's opt we need a
show function that's going to convert a
maybe string to a string and if it's
many we're gonna need something that's
going to work for a list of strings if
you're a Haskell expert you know that
all of these functions are actually
called show but the example gets really
confusing if I just put show show show
right we need to figure out that we have
a show function for each type of data
and what we have to do this pattern
match in order to do it
order we're in Haskell we're not in
address we're not a nagda we're not in
cough how do we we don't have a PI type
alright so here's where high school uses
something that's called a singleton type
right so a singleton time there's a way
of connecting some type level data to
runtime data in a tight enough
connection so that we can kind of do the
same thing all right so here I'm showing
the definition for a singleton type for
my occurrence information and you can
see that for each of these variants of a
occurrences I have a corresponding data
pin structure that matches it right and
s wants the singleton for once is the
only way I can get something of that
type and so what that means here when
I'm mad at matching on s once that tells
me what o is that tells Haskell what it
was so we know oh it's going to be once
so we know ock type once is going to be
string so we know this is the show
function that we need so this is the
really the only change we need to do to
make the code that we wanted to write
actually work we had to draw in these
Singleton's and here i'm i'm using the
singleton library i put this code in
italics because the singleton library
can actually generate this definition
for me it's pretty mechanical okay so
the last bit that shows up when you're
doing dependently type programming is
equivalence proofs
kind of proofs of equality and the
reason this shows office we're working
with these really rich types they have
computations embedded inside them the
type checker is asking this question all
the time is this type equal to that type
well it needs to ask is this computation
equal to that computation that's a hard
question for a type checker to answer it
get pretty good at it so I did there's a
I mean touch owners are pretty good
about reasoning about equivalence but
they're not perfect
they can't be perfect so we sometimes
the programmer needs to step in and be
able to help the type checker reason
about that equivalence and that happens
here and in this example right so let me
I'm going to dive in more to the
implementation of this library I showed
you we had these constructors like our
Sikhs they're actually these smart
constructors they wrap the real data
constructors for my abstract syntax of
regular expressions the real ones they
have the same types as the smart
constructors the smart constructors do a
little bit of optimization before they
actually create like a sequence regular
expression right so this this makes my
code a little bit more efficient because
we can as we build regular expressions
we don't need to put in like for example
if you said okay first match the empty
string then match something else all
right that does that's the same is just
doing the second thing right that
doesn't change what the raw
regular expression is there's several
different identities on regular
expressions we can take advantage of
that right the hapis is type check all
right we have these we have these index
types around right and when we get to
this line the type checker actually has
to do a little bit of proof all right
because we said the result type of this
function is the merge of the two
arguments but we're providing our two
which just has this type so we need to
know that the merge is equal to s2 but
we have the additional information that
we know s1 is empty isn't it is
empty occurrence map just now and the
time checker can do this because I can
look at the definition of merge and it
knows if you merge and the an empty list
it doesn't change right so just from the
definition of merge it can figure this
one out so sometimes the type checker
works sometimes though you have to give
it a hand so here's another example so
this is another one of my smart
constructors this is for the cleany star
where we're going to iterate a regular
expression and you know the last case
we're just going to call the regular
star star constructor but we have two
optimizations that we want to look for
right if you iterate the regular
expression that matches an empty string
that's the same as matching an empty
string zero or more empty strings
matches an empty string right so for
this line though for it to tun check
that optimization the type checker has
to do this little proof that says if you
didn't match anything if your occurrence
map is empty and you repeat empty it's
empty right and empty is just nil so
that first case tells us exactly what we
want this is our definition of how
repeating things works for these
occurrence maps what about this case
here we're going to be repeating
something no ok what is this if you if
you repeat something that's already been
repeated that's also the same as if you
just do it once all right so we're
getting rid of two stars in a row right
so to do that we go to the type checker
here this is something that the type
checker can't do for us right here we
need an identity that the type checker
doesn't know and here's the error
message it gives if you when I was
developing this I got to this point and
I got this type error message and it
says Stephanie I couldn't figure this
out
alright I couldn't figure out well
repeat s is equal to s under the
constraint that s is equal to repeat S
one well what is it telling me right
it's telling me it can't figure out that
if you repeat something twice that's the
same as repeating at once now I can go
and I can look at this definition I say
okay what does a repeat do goes through
every single one of these pairs in the
list and it turns
the currents too many right we're under
a star we don't know how many times it's
gonna happen what if we do that twice
we're just going to turn all these menus
too many again all right so that's true
right so that's something that we want
the type checker to be able to prove
that we could sit down and do a little
proof but how does the type checker do
that all right so in this case I need to
tell the type checker that and so I'm
going to tell the type and get the type
checker to prove it for me using the
type class system so I'm gonna make the
class of a currents map so I'm calling
it WF for well-formed occurrence maps
that satisfies exactly the property that
I want right so an occurrence map is
well-formed if you repeat it twice is
the same as repeating at once that's
exactly the information type checker
needs okay now I need I have two kinds
of occurrence maps I have empty ones and
they're well formed and the type checker
can verify this case we can say yeah
empty maps are well-formed because it
plugs in the empty map there it reduces
the repeats empty is equal to empty
great here's my inductive step I say an
occurrence map right is well-formed
if the tail of it is well-formed it
turns out
Haskell can do this automatically too I
have to guide the induction I think
provide it with the induction hypothesis
but that's all it needs to be able to
show it for this case as well right
that's it that's my entire proof right
and then I need to get that reasoning to
the right place and so I had to go back
to my code base and add just some well
for - constraints to wherever I needed
it both to that data type for regular
expressions but also for these smart
constructors right and so when I'm doing
this and I get to this case here in my
context I have the information that the
type checker exactly needed and so this
time it just goes through automatically
I don't have to do anything to
explicitly apply this proof that I did I
the type the class resolution has fished
it to exactly the place that I need it
to have its fished it everywhere but the
type checker can find it now this wasn't
the only proof I had to do when I was
finishing my library I I had other
things you know are all two-hour seek
they did some optimizations too and so I
needed to other properties right and so
I already had the well form class and so
I added the new properties to it my
proof didn't change these were also
properties that were true by just very
simple inductive arguments all right so
I was able to add those properties and
then they were available where I needed
it okay so what have we seen all right I
tried to kind of point out where we're
doing things like dependently type
languages in haskell so what does that
mean how does haskell stack up as a
dependently typed language right so let
me just kind of go back through all four
of these things that we've seen and kind
of compare what's going on and Haskell
versus what's going on elsewhere all
right so we started with type
computation and here I want to argue
house was really good
for type computation right I showed you
like the example I showed you it's using
it was using some of these operators
that allow you to write functions and
types we have data to use those type
functions it looks a lot like functional
programming except everything is
capitalized right that wasn't the only
way I could have done and I could have
also there's the parts I didn't show you
did a lot of type level computation
based on the class system using class
resolution and these two things can
interact with each other and that's
exactly how that domain-specific error
message works out and that compile time
resolution for that dictionary access so
it's great that these things work
together so well and they also work
together in a context where we didn't
really have to care about termination
right Haskell
even even if the functions that were
writing at the type language we haven't
proven that they terminate we know
Haskell is still types out I mean what
about index types well something like
gadgets has been in Haskell for over ten
years now they're pretty mature there's
been some recent extensions that improve
the support of gadgets that that now it
with the last type and type thing there
is fewer and fewer add to examples that
we can't go and write in Haskell here we
don't have a PI type in Haskell so here
I'm gonna say it's okay
we had to fake that example that we
wanted to write with a PI type using
Singleton's it worked well in this
example that I showed you it doesn't
always work well Singleton's can
sometimes really clutter up your code
some of my current work I've been
working with my collaborator of Richard
Eisenberg we're working to actually go
put a real PI type into Haskell and then
finally for the equivalence proofs here
things it's more like the Wild West
there's lots of different ways to do it
it's not clear how what's the best way
to do these equivalents clues I showed
you one way based on the type class
system there are other ways you could do
it based on type level programming you
can try to do it more like how Agda and
Idris and caulk approach equivalence
proofs but has those logic is much
weaker so it's not quite the same
Gigi also provides something I didn't
show you called solver plugins where you
can just throw it a special
domain-specific solver for the kinds of
equivalents proofs come that come from
your application or you could skip all
the equivalents proofs if you want by
adding axioms or by creating a phantom
type right so it's not clear to me what
the best way forward but there's lots of
fun things to play around with and
really what we're doing when we're in
this domain we're doing program
verification that's always a hard topic
and the more that we can do here the
more exciting it is okay
so I'm just going to wrap up with that
and kind of thank you for your attention
and hope that you're convinced that
we're doing some really fun things with
dependent types in GHC and I hope you'll
be able to play around with it too if
you want to see the full example I put
the full example on my github there's a
repo d th for dependently type haskell
that's where i collect examples like
this one and others of fun things that
you can do with dependent types in
Haskell I also want to thank a lot of my
collaborators who have worked with me on
these extensions to haskell over the
years and especially the National
Science Foundation that has provided a
lot of the funding for my research over
the past couple years okay so thank you
[Applause]